hey everybody and welcome to this video
unfortunately in the first place i
apologize for my voice i'm getting a
little sick here but um i apologize for
that i'm just going to go over today
the new iphone 3.0 software that has
come out and pardon me i'm going on my
uh my notepad document here to actually
pull it up for you it was released today
march 17th by apple um is going to be
and a free upgrade for iphone users okay
so the the original iphone had iphone
version 1.0 software then the iphone 3g
got version 2.0 software and etc now we
have version 3.0 software and i don't
know about anything hardware related yet
but we'll get into that so first of all
um copy cut and paste for the iphone is
a big thing that everyone was waiting
for everyone said if they could get the
size on the iphone that would be a great
thing and they finally did it so they
have copy cut and paste on the iphone
something about a double tap and you
have a little bubble popping up saying
you could um copy cut and paste so
that's a really nice feature actually
a lot of people have been waiting for
that again the iphone had a lot of
features that a lot of phones didn't
have already but this is one of the
features that
it was lacking and now it finally does
have that it's making it just more
complete the next thing i have is um
there's push notifications so um it's
it's not really what we were expecting
about like background tasks if you watch
my um i'll post a video response as my
predictions video i'll link the two
videos together so you can see what my
predictions were a few days before today
um
yeah it's not really background tasks
but you could get like an instant
message or a text message
um while you're playing a game and
you'll get a little little bubble or a
notification that'll say you got the
message but it's not like more than one
task running at once but again um it's
push notifications so that's good uh the
next thing we have is um
what did i even say okay we have neat
voice memos it's not really that
exciting that we have voice memos but um
like i'll show you on my phone here uh
you may or may not be able to hear this
but if i just uh hold it down hold down
one of the buttons on the lg board or
hit the ok button to start recording
and it stopped it starts recording so
you can just say like oh pick up the
groceries i need milk lettuce juice and
then hit stop and it'll save it as a
file and you can always have that file
for later reference so the iphone
finally has that built in again just
basic features completing the whole
iphone um no iphone software thing um
spotlight it's going to have um two
little things in spotlight number one
you're going to be able to have a source
uh a search feature in a lot of
applications so your email your texting
a whole bunch of different clients
you'll be able to search uh your music
on your ipod obviously you'll be able to
search all your music and um it's a
really nice spotlight feature and second
you're gonna have like little spotlight
icon this is an iphone obviously it's
not an iphone but you'll have a little
spotlight icon on the desktop if your
iphone in the yoga you'll be able to
click it and search through all your
applications for everything you need so
that's pretty cool it's really useful
it's a lot more useful than you might
think but it's really good for um
what people will be looking for in a
spotlight like if you're used to mac os
10.
um it has finally a landscape keyboard
i've been talking about this this isn't
nearly the width of an iphone but before
iphone users were or stuck with a
portrait keyboard you would always have
the vertical up and down keyboard and
you would just have to type with that
that was for texting that was for
everything except for entering a url
into a web browser now we have the full
landscape keyboard or yes landscape
keyboard you can turn it sideways and
take use of the entire gorgeous screen
you have i mean it'll make it much
faster for texting for emailing all
these things are going to be built in a
ton of different apps so that's going to
be really good
and obviously mms has come out mms is
now available for the iphone uh 3.0
software so you'll be able to send more
than one picture or at least a picture
or a contact or a calendar event or a
sound file as a message via text message
so it's going to be sms and mms
available for the iphone 3g so again a
lot of these features
which were available on a lot of other
phones before are now available for the
iphone 3 or 3.0 software just making it
more complete a lot of the features it
did not have
as a really great multimedia phone with
an ipod and everything are
being put together into one great
software package
i did in my predictions video predict
some sort of a camera update and there's
not much happening to the camera still
no video
um so i'll get back to you guys maybe
they're waiting for new hardware maybe
they're not gonna they're not telling us
yet about anything about hardware
they're going to be releasing as of
march 17th on the calendar behind me so
we'll we'll see about that we'll see
what happens
um and last but not least
um we have in-game voice so you could
have um
you could have well i already i didn't
say story of bluetooth yet but you can
have stereo bluetooth headphones and
everything going on with your iphone um
so in-game voice is like you could be
playing a game with your friend who's in
your neighbor who's playing on his
iphone and you want to
tether up your games or whatever you can
actually play the game at the same time
hear each other's voice kind of like
xbox i don't know how to describe it but
that's what it's called so if you do
want to look at the
um if you do want to look at the keynote
i'll throw a link in the description you
guys can watch it i'm pretty sure that's
that way i don't remember but again look
at the description there's a whole video
on it on apple.com and um i hope you
guys like this so um this is my basic
breakdown of the iphone 3.0 software
overview um
i'll get back to you guys with more
videos obviously sorry my phone's
ringing i'll get back to you guys with
more videos and hopefully you'll get a
better look at the iphone 3.0 software
i'll do the best i can so thanks for
watching this one and subscribe peace